fun fact she used to hand out flyers for
a gym at Grand Central Station which
inspired her character on Broad City
please welcome someone I love
[Applause]
excited because the last time we met
over Zoom yeah we this is our first time
meeting in real life and it's every
[Applause]
everything in fact I got so excited that
I decided to text your bestie Elana
Glazer and said hey Abby's coming on the
show tomorrow you know do you have any
questions or ideas and she was like ooh
good thinking to ask me
how it started oh no
um she is a multi-talented hyphenate on
League just like Broad City writing show
running producing in addition to acting
how does she do it all
um how did how does she do it all I
think wearing a lot of hats on a thing
which you know what that's like too is I
think when it when you I'm really proud
of the thing that we're put out into the
world and so that makes all of it worth
it like it's it is very hard to do all
those things and The more I've been
doing it the more I kind of realize that
it's a little tricky to have that
balance between life and work but It
ultimately I'm so proud of the pro the
product I'm not sure I have a good
answer for this it's kind of like
compartmentalizing those roles and just
trying to be as present as you can while
you're doing each role but it's also
okay that it's a little sloppy okay so
is it true that when you were a kid you
have this creative Arty side and you've
always had it and your family and you
did a talk show when you were when you
were
yeah my parents were
really just adorable parents and
um my dad I guess got a video camera
camcorder and he we did this
uh talk show where my brother was
Arsenio Grimley which is like dating
only a couple people might understand
both those references so it's like oh I
get that yeah it's a mix of Arsenio Hall
I was on arsenia I'm sure I'm sure of
course you were
I still did
without the it was the best he lacked
formality and he had coolness so is that
what spoke to you well it wasn't my
ideas it was my parents idea so it was a
it was a mix between Arsenio Hall and Ed
Grimley okay that's a very different
person which is yeah it's character
that's like on SNL that I was like like
I don't even know
I can't even really do the impersonation
but my yeah my high pants by the way I
usually in like lots of energy yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and a little like right and then he was
like like the hair came up everything I
want people to see right now too
I'm getting a mistress
by the way I kind of am dressed like
I'm like a Charlie girl
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah remember
the Charlie girl
thank you
my parents
my brother was Arsenio Grimley and he
hosted the show and I was every guest
and I I was so young but I I would just
come out and sing
[Laughter]
um Alana asked another question she said
she just got engaged to her beautiful
um GF who's also an actor and I think
she might enjoy talking about this is
this true like are is she are you gonna
kill her right now or are you like okay
because I know you're a very private
person yeah I am private but I I did
just get engaged
[Applause]
yeah and Jody's an actor too so I mean
like it's impossible to be
as private maybe as you would like but
yeah I'm very happy and excited have
done nothing to plan said wedding but
that will happen at some point I guess
well we're just we all of us Alana are
so happy for you thanks I'm really happy
thank you now when Ilana came on this
show I have an image because you guys I
couldn't believe like I was ever
mentioned in Broad City by the way this
is my daughter I mentioned a lot I love
this I know I know
but
I was always so excited and um there's
one episode where you guys talk about
this Burton bag that I I wrote an
article about yeah I had it this morning
they've discontinued it oh I should hang
on do it okay mother you know what's the
Burton how dare you
please bring that bag back it's so
amazing so now that you can't get that
bag guess what I have a new luggage
Obsession and I brought one for you as a
gift no yes
thank you goodness okay so this is the
new North Face bag so it's a duffel one
minute but then boom hold on it becomes
a backpack
so
so this is my new gift to you because
well you know we love that we you love
that you love them and for your
adventures that you go on and I since I
got Alana of Crescent it was only right
look at this
[Applause]
[Music]